in nevada's tribal areas voter
participation was being encouraged by a
non-profit
some very nice prizes were handed out in
order to encourage
people to vote in the 2020 presidential
election
there were even 500 gift cards
now the nevada native voting project
said it had
no agenda it simply wanted to increase
election participation
and because it did not seem to be
partisan
the nevada indian commission a state
agency had no problem getting involved
on the nevada indian commission facebook
page six posts
offering gift cards via raffle were
shared
in addition to that the nevada indian
commission offered its own prizes
raffling off three major pieces of art
to those who voted
people may not be aware but encouraging
people to vote
with rewards is illegal whoever makes or
offers to make an expenditure to any
person either to vote or withhold his
vote
or to vote for or against any candidate
shall be fined
under this title or imprisoned but
nobody got the memo and in fact
a reno sparks indian colony official was
even
filmed handing out the loot we have 25
25 gift cards to raffle off so that's a
lot of money cash here
the excuse is that this is simply a
non-partisan effort
not aimed at helping any candidate or
party except there are
indications to the contrary nevada is a
swing state
and nevada has over 60 000 registered
native american voters
who could really make the difference in
our states
make sure you get out here get some
biden harris campaign
swag is because they have masks they
have a t-shirt
signs stickers all kinds of stuff hand
sanitizer
all right guys you have it there she has
some biden cookies for you
all to support rsic to get out the vote
get to the polls and and vote for who
you think
is best the facebook page of the native
voter project
even shared a post from an ngo called
the
native organizers alliance and that made
clear that their aim was to flip the
electoral map from red to blue
not surprisingly a lawsuit was filed by
the nevada republican party
there was schemes set up
give voters something of value raffle
tickets t-shirts
other things like that if they would
come and vote
something that violates federal law
something that violates nevada law
now the nevada native voter project says
they didn't do anything
wrong they say that this was simply a
nonpartisan effort to encourage voting
and furthermore they point out that no
member of their staff or any of their
volunteers ever attended any
biden-harris events
however their statements did leave out
those 500
gift cards us officials have actually
condemned the government of venezuela
for offering incentives to encourage
voter participation but in nevada i
guess it's okay
now keep in mind that native americans
vote pretty consistently for the
democratic party
it looks here like a state agency was
involved in a very targeted campaign
to encourage vote participation from a
constituency that leans a certain way
nothing wreaks a clean transparent
elections then handing out valuable
freebies and prizes to encourage certain
people to vote
in america at least you know we we don't
think that there would be any corruption
in our government and so you would
assume that this would be some non-party
non-state actor
or organization that was just corrupt
and doing something wrong
so when we see things like in nevada
where you have the state authorities you
have a government authority
um participating in this uh scheme
participating in these things that that
interfere with our election
that's what's been most troubling i
think for the american
population of course and in other
countries people are
used to governments uh that might be
corrupt or to state officials that might
be corrupt
and in america we're finally starting to
see that that has happened that's the
most troubling thing with nevada
you